le québec château fort de la langue
française en amérique du nord est
toujours mais ses remparts ses criques
presque partout dans la province le
français recule
77 2 5% de la population parle
régulièrement la langue à la maison il
ya cinq ans c'était 79% ou même moment
plus d'un million de résidents du québec
adq l'anglais comme première langue
officielle
un record dans le cas de l'anglais au
québec depuis fort possible que ce soit
lié en fait à des recteurs en grande
partie à des facteurs migratoire nombre
de résidents non permanents qui se sont
établis au québec de façon générale de
2016 et 2021 a été en augmentation pour
le premier ministre le go en tout cas
c'est une nouvelle occasion de justifie
sa loi sur la langue française adoptée
aux médias
ni raison d'âge et
le gouvernement trudeau lui aussi se dit
préoccupé et espère que sa modernisation
de la loi sur les langues officielles
sera votée dans les prochains mois nous
sommes les premiers gouvernements et
reprenait le français est en déclin dans
ces pays et puis c'est pour cette raison
nous allons l'avant avec une loi qui est
ambitieuse mais aussi avec un rédaction
et les partis d'opposition lui reproche
de faire partie du problème et non de la
solution le gouvernement doit plus
les lois doit en plus de mordant pour
faire respecter
le français partout au canada
son projet de loi ne renforce pas le
français il vient pêcher à mamadou kébé
d'appliquer la loi 101 aux entreprises
de compétence fédérale
tous les indicateurs sont tous
à l'extérieur du québec aussi les
indicateurs sont au rouge au nouveau
brunswick seule province bilingue
la proportion de ceux qui ont le
français comme première langue parlée
est passé de 31,6 à 30% en cinq ans en
ontario de 3,8 3 4 pour cent au manitoba
de 3,1 à 2 7% d'entrepôts communauté
fédération des communautés francophones
et acadiennes la solution est claire il
faut attirer plus d'immigrants qui
parlent français dans ces provinces si
on avait respecté les l'immigration
francophone au canada à l'extérieur du
québec on aurait eu des gains les
données du recensement sont sans appel
et met donc plus de pression sur le
gouvernement trudeau pour qu'il adopte
sa modernisation de la loi sur les
langues officielles au plus vite mais
même avec ce projet de loi plusieurs
doutent que ce sera suffisant pour
vraiment freiner le déclin du français
au pays ici leur enceinte et radio
canada ottawa